clayton kershaw has faced arizona 36
times in his career
16 times in this ballpark and how about
these numbers in those 16 starts he's
10-1
with a 150 here against him he's always
loved pitching to dodger stadium and
he's responded to losing streaks of the
dodgers and rough outings of his own his
last one was a little bit rough
five earned runs but he got a w he
supported very well
i think one of the things that could
turn him around tonight is to use that
arm side
fastball that foundational pitch of his
inside fastball to righties
or away to lefties is getting hit around
a little bit in his rough outings but if
he goes
arm side and use the other side of the
plate the league's only hitting 143 off
it two out escobar switch hitter batting
for the right side
and a fly ball to left field to zugo
going back
and on the warning track he makes the
catch pretty good poke for escobar comes
a couple of feet
short no runs no hits a man left matt
peacock steps on the dodger stadium
mound for the first time ever
matt not named the starter for this one
until about 3
30 this afternoon so the element of
surprise here
we know about matt peacock he's going to
pound that sinker down in the zone
it's in the occasional breaking ball
occasional change up but
you'll know he's at his best if you're
seeing a lot of ground balls to the
infielders
fly ball gets a pretty deep right moving
back onto pavon smith at the wall and
excuse me rojas makes a catch
in right field two on the other cross
again in right field tonight
and he took in that long deep drive off
the bat at turner
top two no score dodgers trying to move
to 7-1 on this home stand
15-6 overall at home this year he's got
his first strikeout tonight
he now moves one ahead of warren spahn
into 28th place on the all-time
strikeout list
and now david peralta back to the slider
tapped along first
chased by barnes running through to get
him
heck of a play austin barnes
sprinting down the first base line about
halfway between home and first
from his knees he was able to make the
throw and get
peralta first what a play by austin
barnes
just to get to the ball to begin with
that's more than a third of the way down
the lineup
playing right field batting seventh so
far it's been six up six down for
peacock
popped up into center la castro comes in
still coming in there now has it one out
seven up seven down to start the night
for matt here's austin barnes the
catcher
ground ball down to third escobar's got
it throws the first nice play to get him
and austin barnes has retired for round
number two that wasn't a real easy play
and
eduardo made it look easy here's kershaw
now
four for 13 this year oprah two is a
pinch hitter pop flies shadow center
field
for castro to end at nine pitch nine up
nine down for the 27 year old rookie
that peacock is
allowed one base runner and they hit
tim lacaster on the foot and it'll be
the castro to lead off this
inning reaches out swats one to second
diving
chris taylor making just his sixth start
of the year at second base had to be
perfect and he was
the castro trying to go the other way
quickly to his left taylor makes a
diving play and throws out the speedy le
castro
with a head first slide at first
diamondbacks have had the only two base
runners where they hit batter and now
walk
escobar flying out his first time up and
he swings hits it to deep center
going back on it at the warning track at
the wall touch them all eduardo
a two-round homer and a two-nothing
diamondback lead
he crushed that ball roma scores ahead
of him and the diamondbacks strike first
here tonight against kershaw on top two
nothing
and a boy congratulations i'm proud of
you
well neila beacon is straight away
center
this is the 10th start this year by
clayton kershaw that's only the fifth
whole month he's given up
no runs on just one base runner through
three and two thirds against the rookie
tonight
and tsugo is coming up slaps it
basically to left field
muncie gets the wave headed home
peralta's throw us off line
and yoshi with his first rbis at dodger
it's a 2-1 game of thinking man's in bet
on a full count and cesugo did not try
and pull that pitch the previous pitch
was tailing away from him as
this one was as well you go with it
you've got a big hole the left side and
the dodgers creep back within a run
infield will come in as the pitcher
peacock comes up
lays the butt down there's a safety
squeeze ahmed not going anywhere but it
gets behind muncie
are they going to say it's interference
they are
he's out and now that will have to go
back to third
a huge call right there that is always
going to bring an argument tory develop
comes out wants to talk this over with
will little
but they're gonna say that matt peacock
went out of his way to get in front of
that throw
the ball did hit peacock in the back of
the left leg he's inside the line that's
automatically out
i'm not entirely sure why lavello is
as worked up as he is and he's just been
thrown out of the game
troy lavello's thrown out with his team
having lost 12 of its last 15.
for to start from matt peacock his
second career big league start is here
at dodger stadium to sell the dodgers to
a run over
five and a third the runners at first
and third though his responsibility
second and third base hit here the
dodgers can take the lead
ground ball right side fielded by young
his throw to first is in time
no runs two hits and two men left
diamondbacks bullpen with a one-run lead
in the seventh walks the first two
batters in the inning
and now it's albert pujols he pops one
behind
first back
[Applause]
it hit a little leather before it hit
the grass but he did his job
we're gonna look for one here from will
smith loop into right
and it's off the glove of rojak
in the score is betts on his way
home is lux the dodgers get a break
at a 3-2 lead still just one goal
that's looking for his first hit tonight
right center field sending the caster on
the move
he won't get there the d-box takes a
break as it bounces into the seats
but it brings home another run and the
dodgers lead 4-2
on a mookie bets double up to andrew
young
trying to keep it alive for david
peralta bouncing ball to second
takes a tough bounce but taylor loves it
cleanly and ends the night
jansen passes accuracy alone in third
for the most saves with one team